- [Collin Sexton:] I didn't call for the
screen just because I
knew I could get around him.
And I knew I had a
little bit of burst.
This is Collin Sexton
from the
Cleveland Cavaliers,
and I'm gonna take you
through some of my
most exciting plays.
I'm always watching
the second defender,
and I'm just pretty
much reading the big
and reading if anyone's
gonna step up.
I didn't call for the
screen just because I
knew I could get around him.
And I knew I had a
little bit of burst
that I could use against him.
I just told him
just to stay back,
and I knew I could get
my defender on my hip.
And once I did, I was able
to get in front of him.
I stopped a little bit,
and I got the bump,
and then I was able to shoot the
little mini-floater right here.
Just my off-the-dribble
move package,
just depending on the
player. The bigger guys I
have to make sure I get shifted.
Being one of the top players
in three-point percentage
when it's clutch time just
shows that all the work that I'm
putting in is gonna
pay off, and just
showing the time that I spend
in the gym, and the time
that I spend out
there on the floor.
This was one of my best
games in my career.
We didn't have that much
time left on the clock,
and I knew where I
wanted to get to,
and I knew Larry [Nance Jr.]
was coming up to slip out.
Once he slipped out, either
if his man jumped out,
Larry would've been wide open.
Going left is what I
like to do, especially
like pulling up from three.
So I knew that once I got
a little bit of daylight,
I was going to just
shoot it regardless.
And miss or make, I was gonna
live with the attempt.
It just came in, and
I knocked it down.
I knew I had to make sure
I flipped my wrist just enough
because I knew Kyrie [Irving]
was playing really good defense
right here.
Whenever I draw two, or
whenever I create a trap—
whether it's off a pick-and-roll,
or even like a pindown
where two come to
me—then I always
try to look for the
nearest man or open man.
And they might swing
it to someone else.
I didn't realize that I get
doubled eighth in the league
until now.
It just shows teams,
they respect me,
that I am growing, as well as
just getting better
as a player.
So right here, I knew
I didn't have the shot.
I seen three, I think three
or four people in front of me.
So I just pretty much
kicked the ball back out.
Once I kicked the
ball back out, I've
seen the shot clock was down,
so the only thing that I was thinking
is if he swings it back, I gotta
get it up. I gotta shoot it.
So once he swung
it back to me,
I was ready to shoot and
in position to shoot.
I'm glad I knocked it down,
because this was a big shot.
Those are the types of metrics
that we pretty much think
about, is trying to
go quick, or even
like the two-for-one
situation side,
so I can be able to get to my
spot and be able to pull up.
But some of the guys that are
my height and some people that
are guarding me,
I'm able to just,
to pretty much get to my spot.
Because I know I can get enough
elevation and enough
rise in my shot that I can
pretty much shoot over him.
The metrics just
pretty much just show
I think I run a lot
faster than most people.
That's something that I use
for my advantage on offense,
as well as on defense as well.
It's kind of hard to stop
the ball when someone's
running full speed at you.
We've been doing
pretty much just
tracking my top speeds and
some of my average speeds
just recently.
And they've been
getting up in numbers.
I can use my speed to get up
to 15, 16, 17 miles an hour.
Then those are the
chances that I want
to make sure I capitalize on.
You're taught at a young
age: If you give it up,
you get it back.
That's just simple
basketball, especially when
it's a two-on-one.
You always give it
up to get it back.
It's hard to defend that,
especially on two-on-one.
If I continue to hold
the ball, I probably
wouldn't even got an
easy layup like this.
Just taking that
extra two more steps
allow me to even get
a wide-open layup.
That's just plain and
simple right there.
I definitely overshot the
layup, just because I was
running a little bit too fast.
I'm gonna take these
metrics and just pretty much
just continue watching, focus
on the areas that I do well at
and just continue to get
better at those areas,
as well as add more metrics
into it and more things
that I feel like will
help me along the way.
Thanks for checking out this
episode of "The Breakdown."